er ist jung hat studiert aber er
verkauft sich für billiges geld eine
kampagne gegen lohndumping
die idee stammt von diesen beiden
geschäftspartner gedrückt es war das
loben gegen kreativ prostitution
bewohner von verhindern dass die leute
nicht unter wert verkaufen
aber ihn zu niedriglöhnen in der
kreativbranche damit haben sie auch so
eine erfahrung gemacht deshalb gründeten
sie ihre vermittlungsagentur für
kreative es gibt auf der einen seite die
entwicklung dass leute immer mehr
ausgebeutet werden plattformen wo man
dann 100 leute irgendwie ein logo
designern und nur der gewinner erhält
sein geld dafür doch gehen wir einfach
absolut die ausbeutung die berliner
kreativ branche trifft sich in solchen
hippel workspaces webdesigner texter
fotografen
doch manche von ihnen müssen mit
honoraren auf sozialhilfeniveau
auskommen
knapp 1000 euro im monat in ihrem
firmenvideo zeigen die jobvermittler die
die arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer
zusammen bringen sie vermitteln die
kreativen zu einem festen tages hat
viele sagen ja immer 300 euro als
tagesvater das klingt zu viel
das ist ganz normal für leute die mit
finanzen nichts zu tun haben
aber wenn man das mal hoch und runter
rechnet kommt man halt schnell darauf
dass man da keine rente von freien kann
dass man nichts davon zurück zurücklegen
kann
es ist grafikdesignerin
sie wurde von den beiden an eine
werbeagentur vermittelt dafür erhalten
sie zehn prozent provision von ihrem opa
dann ging es eigentlich relativ schnell
alles klappt innerhalb von zwei tagen
hat die erste agentur angerufen und dann
eine woche später die nächste und
mittlerweile gibt es auch agenturen die
werden auch wieder kommen
berlin ein eldorado für die
internationale kreativ geht doch hier
jeden dritten reich das geld kaum zum
leben statt alleine zu hause zu sitzen
arbeitet etwa charles lieber zusammen
mit anderen selbstständigen
hier findet sie anregungen kontakte und
manchmal auch neue jobs
ihr tagessatz erscheint hoch auf den
ersten blick also theoretisch fängt bei
54 1 250 500 euro und wie oft kommt sehr
darauf an im sommer ist es ganz offen
dass man erst einmal geprüft wird aber
das heißt jetzt auch nicht jeden tag
sondern das ist dann vielleicht ein
zweimal im monat dann ist aber auch
wieder zwei monate nicht
weltweit wächst der markt für die
kreative wohin sie sind jung wollen
unabhängigkeit
doch über die schattenseiten sprechen
sie ungern nach jedem auftrag wartet die
ungewissheit die sind gewerkschaftlich
nicht organisierten fehlen
tarifabschlüsse ihre schöne heile welt
belächeln manche mit zynismus tages das
über alle tages gesagt
in der kategorie denke ich gar nicht
du kriegst genug geld damit du nicht
hast und das ist es dann auch und dann
arbeitest du irgendwie zwischen 8 und 16
stunden 20 manchmal auch 24 aber in
parkplätzen gratuliert aber die grafik
designerin hat sie sich dazu gelernt auf
lohndumping legte sich heute nicht mehr
ein mann dann auch um seine eigene
energie und auch unseren eigenen dass
man auch seine unkosten hatten doch muss
man einfach auch hingehen und um grenzen
rettung in ganz deutschland arbeiten 15
millionen menschen in der kreativbranche
aber anderes als esther schaffen ist die
meisten nicht den wert ihrer arbeit auch
durchzusetzen